ground ball to first
bobbled and they'll only get the one out
it should have been a double play and
ending over but
mancini struggled with that ball
right at the second baseman it's kicked
off by wilkerson
and everybody's safe and so an error
keeps the inning alive
second defensive miscue of this opening
frame for baltimore
right center field base hit bradley does
it again
scoring is hernandez rosario in the
third
it's a two-out rbi single for bobby
bradley
and a one-nothing indians lead in the
first bradley continues to hit
with two outs and runners in scoring
position did a nice job here look like a
slider he got
and drives it into right center field
so josh naylor with two down and another
chance for stevie
this one he'll make and the inning is
over a cleveland run
at a one-nothing lead after one
added that power dimension last couple
of years of his career
that a breaking ball here is hammered
into right nailed her back at the wall
it is off the top of the fence
bounces right back to naylor and galvez
hit it so
darn hard he's gonna have to stop it
first
well you see this at yankee stadium i
mean if if he was a uh
well he is a right-handed hitter but if
he was hitting right-handed maybe fenway
where you wrap it off the green monster
that ball's driven to left field by
franco muscle deep
zimmer the center fielder at the wall
and this is off the fence
galvez racing around third and he will
score
franco drives in galvez a couple of wall
balls for the o's
and a tie game in the second
cal comes off the mound will make the
flip inning over
orioles get a run on two hits leave one
man stranded middle of the second we're
tied at one
and baltimore going to try and take a
lead here d.j stewart struck out his
first time up
not this time quantrill strikes out
stewart for the second time tonight
and the oh strand a pair six for nine
against the orioles this year
and harvey gets him swinging on a
one-two high
heat from matt harvey who is through
three innings without an
earned run allowed on half of the fourth
josh naylor to lead it off grounded out
his only time up
naylor launches one deep right center
field that's in the alley and it is that
a short hop defense
and he's in the second base with a lead
off double that's his 12th
two bagger of the year good battle here
ernie clement trying to get that runner
over
slowed it down and he based it into
center field
his first big league hit almost drove in
a run
he's gonna go to second naylor was going
back to third the ball to the backstop
he's gonna score
and ernie heads up goes into third base
oh yeah
the upstate new york kid gets it rolling
here in the fourth
and the indians have a two to one lead
well there's your energy andre right
there
he had a nice at bat to get that base
hit and
actually naylor was going to go back to
third
they're doing them a favor they're
certainly making it a lot easier for him
broken bad it's a base hit into right
field for zimmer
clement will score it's three to one the
shattered shard of that bat was heading
towards
stevie wilkerson so it kind of put him
in instant exit mode
the only guy that may have had a shot at
it was mancini
he couldn't get it the ball's into right
field and the indians have another run
there's a ball rifled into right center
field that's gonna score zimmer
hernandez on his way to third and ahmed
rosario
has delivered an rbi single he's two for
three on the night
and it's four to one cleveland that's
the patented swing right there on that
heater
taking it the other way a back-to-back
hits for
ahmed ahmed rosario down at first with
two down for eddie
rosario last time up there's a bullet to
right field
all the way to the wall scoring is cesar
here comes ahmed they're going to wave
him home
here's the throat of the plate he is
safe he's safe at the plate and eddie
goes into third
somehow with a sleight of hand rosario
beat the tag it's a five run fourth for
cleveland
remember the blue jays are winning that
game 5-2 over the yankees in buffalo
mancini with a shot this is gonna carry
to the wall
and you know cedric mullins can run he's
gonna dash from first to home to score
an rbi double trey mancini it is six to
two as the birds get one back
so i'm two bases off instead of a home
run he hits a double
gets an rbi number 48. still mates on
coming on to the third pitcher of the
ball game
swaying and a miss down goes austin
hayes for the first out of the inning
thunder down below too in that seventh
spot although
nathan gets him yeah he went fishing
that time a couple of k's now from may
time
the one 1-2 swing and a miss hay struck
him out
with a wicked curve ball down and in one
for three with an rbi single
bobby bradley with a high fly ball
deep right field that's a moon shot it's
out of here
7-2 cleveland on bobby's third home run
of the year well the first home run of
the night for the indians and bradley
i'll tell you what he tried to sneak
something by him inside and uh
no that didn't work you got your big boy
going tomorrow
savali so you know he's gonna at least
you figure
swung out and miss karen check with the
express
pass santander for route number one
checks payoff pitch blew it by him
almost
knocked austin hedges to the backstop
and there are two down two two
nice got him curveball struck him out
looking and james karen check
strikes out the side in the eighth
clase came into the ninth last night and
face three hitters struck out two of
them
a little chopper up the first baseline
it stays fair
and bradley tags the bag one away
[Music]
bouncing ball up the gut cut off by
ahmed rosario he'll throw to first and
there are two down
in the night swing and a miss he struck
him out
book it the indians win again